the Israeli military says Palestinian
militants Ambush troops in a dense Gaza
City neighborhood Tuesday killing at
least nine of them the fighting comes as
Hamas puts up stiff resistance in areas
that Israel has isolated and pounded
with air strikes for more than two
months senior Foreign Affairs
correspondent Greg palott is in Tel Aviv
tonight a pledge from Benjamin Netanyahu
that Israel will fight until Victory
after one of the deadliest days for the
IDF and its war against
Hamas nine soldiers killed some top
officers along with several injured
Tuesday when amas militants ambushed
troops on a mission in a Gaza City
neighborhood another Soldier killed
further
north the true heroes of Israel my heart
and our hearts go out both to the fallen
and the families we know their lives
have changed Hamas putting up a fight in
other ways sending Rockets against
nearby Israeli
towns its leader declaring any future
government in Gaza without Hamas would
be a
delusion some viral videos of Israeli
soldiers acting in appropriately in Gaza
got a Tamp down from the
military a spokesman saying disciplinary
steps would be taken as the lives of
civilians in Gaza continue to be
disrupted heavy rains turning 10 cities
into a muddy chaos the UN warns of a
major Health crisis the shelters have
long ago exceeded their full capacity uh
with people lining up for hours just to
get to a
toilet and anger grows here among
families of hostages still held in Gaza
a protest in front of the prime
minister's office an emotional rally
tonight in Tel Aviv 28-year-old Adon
Stevie remains a captive his father
wants him home I want my son 67 day no
phone I don't know what you feel
[Music]
you want your son
yes I want my son he says and the
hostage news keeps getting worse an
announcement late this day of the death
of another Hamas captive fought to be
still alive his name is tall haime the
41-year-old was described as a pillar of
his community he leaves behind a wife
and three young children the death
branded a murder Mike Greg palot live
and Tel Aviv Greg thanks very much I'm
Steve duy I'm Brian kilme and I'm Angley
aart and click here to subscribe to the
Fox News YouTube page to catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis